I feel like I'm gonna die
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings
and today we're joined by superwoman
Lilly Singh she's a YouTube juggernaut
with more than 14 million subscribers a
writer producer actress and New York
Times bestselling author but how does
she handle her hot wings we'll find out
today Lilly welcome to the show thanks
so much for thinking I'm cool enough to
be here and you know what I've heard you
say that you're a pansy when it comes to
spices as solved over time or no
absolutely not if anything it's gotten
worse uh I'm the worst ending personal
planet because I can't take spices well
we've got the vegan wings lined up are
you ready to be really yes I am let's do
it
[Music]
it's already hot not amazing / Natalie
Portman's request we get him from blonde
now who I just met actually for a couple
days ago really mm-hmm
was that zeitgeist and she does really
cool talk about just women's rights and
feminism but she's the cool thing she
did she involved men in the conversation
so well and I was like the we did that
is so great cuz when I do that like a
lot of guys are just like shut up then
she did it with such grace is very did
the same with veganism on our show you
know if you can somehow your new Watson
be kind of persuasive the best ways to
involve people in conversation she does
us so well exactly
so as we touched on in your intro you've
been one of the biggest stars in the
internet for the better part of a decade
racking up billions of views tens of
millions of subscribers and hitting a
couple of Forbes lists along the way
what role did a hot ones alum and friend
of the brand Harley Morenstein play and
helping you level up I got us a great
question so when I was starting YouTube
I was a complete loner and loser and
nerd and I knew nothing about it you
know I was living in Toronto and
everyone else was in LA and in the
industry and in in the heart of it all I
slid into Sdn like a Harley you know I
love if you could educate me a little
bit on the YouTube game
it wasn't even creepy or weird he wasn't
even trying to go there he just sat down
with me and just educated me on
everything related to the game and his
conversation is actually what prompted
me to take YouTube seriously and make it
a career so I owe a lot of my success to
Harley shout-out to Harley and beard
goals yeah for sure cannot mine you know
like not very completely well if you
need something you'll see you like don't
but you'll see like a little bit but I'm
working on it so you know and then in
the entertainment industry across the
board but particularly in YouTube
there's this spotlight on mental health
because there's this pressure to deliver
so consistently and then you're met with
all this immediate feedback right do you
feel the same pressure with every upload
to please your audience or does that
ease over time absolutely i I know the
ends are people one here is like you get
thick skin and yeah you get thick skin
when it comes to hate comments and stuff
but every uploads kind of like people
don't like this one it stresses me out
will get as much abuse as the last one
and it's weird because you're self aware
that it's not healthy but you know that
measure
your success by views is not healthy so
some of the lessons I've had to teach
myself is views don't define me
subscribers don't define me and just say
that okay / and I'll hit 15 million I'll
be like just hit 15 in subscribers so
it's like you're self-aware but you
still make bad choices I'm gonna front
for as long as I can I can see the
strength in your eyes it's good so your
list of collaborations is impressive to
say the least talk and first world
problems with Bill Gates having a dinner
date in Hawaii with the rock and then
playing iPhone games with Michelle Obama
and here in the hot ones we know
firsthand how hard it is to target a
high profile celebrity and then get them
to agree right to eat the wings of death
here when you think about all the times
you had to go above and beyond and
hustle for a guest is there a story that
stands out yes Hawaii was super the one
you mentioned with Dwayne was super
challenging because I went there and
they were in the process of promoting
Jumanji so they were really busy and
they had way more important things to do
and every two seconds like just wanted
to run this script by you ultimately
Kevin Hart was not able to do the collab
anymore this was five minutes before we
were supposed to shoot so my day-to-day
manager Kyle had to step in and act
alongside Dwayne five minutes before we
shot the video
Dwayne's friend who literally doesn't
act and we gave the script to 30 seconds
before he was sweating and dying to act
alongside do anybody killed it what are
the mechanics behind shooting with
Michelle Obama I imagine but the Secret
Service the time constrains there's some
moving parts right yeah it's so funny
shooting with Michelle such a huge honor
but obviously there's a lot of protocol
to follow you know I met her first in
the White House so I walk in and someone
came up to me think oh okay so you know
she's gonna come out and she's gonna
meet you right here and then they put a
marker on the ground of where she was
gonna meet me yeah and I said you can
take a selfie with this hand and I'm
like oh my god okay look this at what if
I go with this and they're like we
prefer this hand because of just the way
her hair is gonna be and I'm like okay
she comes out she doesn't hit the mark
she goes on the other side from me I'm
like so I literally look at the girl my
I'm like stressed so I take a picture
with the other head and I'm so scared
Lee to kick me out of the white house
but it's completely fine but yeah there
was a lot of mechanics in there yeah all
right Cheers okay cool one butterfly
bakery smoked onions so I understand
that as a kid you'd walk around with a
world wrestling championship belt as I
paid you you still do it
it's in the green room okay we got it
locked up for you and I've heard you
compare the WWE to Bollywood can you
unpackage that comparison a little bit
for us the thing I love the most about
the WWE's they've taken this really
intense sport and they've added such
wonderful dramatics to it and so when
you watch WWE
there's wrestling but the majority of it
is like trash talk
rip hey trash talk and like all this
drama and all this beef happening and
that's how Bollywood is Bollywood is all
about dramatics and all about theatrics
and I'm really drawn to things like that
cuz I'm so interested in how they can
hook an audience's attention I've been
to so many wrestling events and on
either side of me there's these huge
grown dudes they're like crying at the
results of a match that they know is
orchestrated but I was still crying
about it
I think that's magic truly mango okay
Cole smalls is in my DNA I should be
okay with this get a little hot in here
no I know what it is it's fine yeah
harness it I'm just kidding to make me
feel better
all right so besides your obvious charm
and charisma you've built this YouTube
legacy through your master of the art of
relatability I've heard you say that you
will pour over analytics read comments
and then you have this microprocessor in
your brain where you can do some quick
math and decide whether or not some
is relatable enough and wonder does that
get harder as you get older do you end
up like jay-z on Kingdom Come just
rapping about things no one can relate
to you know what no one has ever asked
me that question and I need to give you
props right now because that's such a
good question because that is absolutely
what happens I really pride myself on my
ability to be relatable now things that
happen in my everyday life annoying
people at the movies there's something I
argued with my parents things that
anyone watch and could be like yeah I
know what that feels like and then they
share with their friends but as my life
gets crazy and I make videos about oh I
hung out with Dwayne I go with the rock
always someone thought I was cool enough
to give me a private jet for the day I
understand that the average person can't
watch that and be like same let me put
some of my modern life pet peeves to you
yeah and then if you just give me the
math as you run it through the
microprocessor if it's relatable enough
to warrant a video okay it's got feeling
anxiety at one of those iPad check out
things cuz the tip options are just 20%
30% absolutely absolutely because I'm a
cheap person and so I'm like what if I
want to give you like 13% you know I
mean what if you don't want the full 15
or 20 label yep super slow airplane
Wi-Fi huh you see yeah you had me an
airplane with airplane Wi-Fi might not
be as relatable right just because when
I lived in Canada a lot of my flights
didn't have Wi-Fi and then when I moved
to America all my American friends like
this 20 hour flight doesn't have Wi-Fi
this is so stupid
that teeters regretting buying a hoodie
for $200 because I saw Jonah Hill
wearing it on Instagram I'm gonna say
that's just you
this is the halfway mark right so we're
gonna go half way further than this
point right now that we're at okay don't
psych yourself out them no no
[Music]
okay we're good
no no we're chill they're good yeah
you'll be okay all right Lilly will
evergreen segments on our show called
explain that Granberry do a deep dive
and I guess Instagram put interesting
pictures that need more context okay so
I'll bust out the laptop I'll show you
the picture you tell me the bigger story
in your Instagram sure is really an
embarrassment of riches you know why
this is bad for foodie because I still
want to keep eating it like I still want
to eat it cuz it's delicious but it
hurts so bad okay I'm not gonna have any
more all right first things first
here you are with James Franco and Seth
Rogen why he went into the vault here
why is kissing Seth Rogen such a unique
experience alright so this so mental
this this was one of the first major
clubs I've ever done in my career this
was years ago before I even lived in LA
and I had this idea to dress up as my
mom and kiss Seth Rogen duh so here's
the thing I don't smoke Seth Rogen does
I've heard lots mmm he does it Lots and
so I think I psyched myself into
believing that I got a secondhand high
from kissing him contact I think so so I
had to kiss him like two to three times
and then I believe that I was high for
the rest of the shoot and so like
everything was just super weird like his
laugh was really weird and loud to me
and so it was a very interesting
experience because I think I got
secondhand high my boogers are on this
now that's okay
it's your napkin to take thank you all
right here we are at the [ __ ] walk of
Amber Rose and of note 21 savage in the
bathroom everyone made fun of this
because literally I was hosting her [ __ ]
walk that year I love her I think she's
so just so full of personality and
character and so I took this picture
with her and I didn't even notice that
he was in the background but if you just
zoom in on his face he's so unimpressed
with me he's just like why are you
posing with my girl like why are you
here why you touching her and so like I
love this picture I'm think about
blowing it up posters eyes all right
thus concludes explaining that gram lose
this is a wrap on this or every
so you can tap out whatever never you'll
never tap out okay this next one is the
Clark and Hopkins a song which one is
this one mm-hmm
this one mm-hmm oh you see when there's
foreign text on it that's when you
really know all right here we go
yes whoa these really big white wires
now you can see now we're starting to
get into like legitimate like yeah this
is like wrong
[Music]
so earlier this year you did a video
about fan accounts spotlighting various
stands again and have you like my ears
are getting it happens on how long I got
you so earlier this year you did a video
about the different kinds of celebrity
stands we've dubbed our fans the spice
Lords mixed reviews do you give that a
thumbs up or do you think we did boys
drawing board there I'm gonna give it a
solid B okay Abby it's it's good though
right right yes that's raw and unicorns
that's not that unique spice start is a
hundred times more unique so I think
yours is better than mine but just so I
know where is the closest washer uh it's
out through the back don't you hang out
in the greenroom
yes there's one in the greenroom is it
soundproof
[Music]
by your water firewater okay why do I
feel like this that's how it happens
that's how it happens this is drool
coming out of my mouth oh no no you know
I was going to say why do I feel like it
doesn't taste hot but then but then it
got hot I've seen so many guests just
skipping through the woods and then step
right into a bear trap just like that
never gets old never gets old
so recently we had Chrissy Teigen I'm
the show and she delivered a
controversial take on wyden atilla's
trash and basically just an excuse for
people to eat chocolate in the morning
you get a response to that
they tell us amazing okay I wish I had a
spoon to tell her right now oh my god
it's really hot I saw that episode
actually you did I loved Chrissy Teigen
completely aware that Nutella is a sugar
it's just sugar but it's really good I
didn't put my tongue in there for the
uninitiated can you explain Tim Hortons
because there seems to be a real cult
following and it's strong with that one
but I'm not sure the American audience
really gets it I guess
Timmy's I believe and people are gonna
hate on me for saying this it's a more
homely version of Starbucks
service like a really long line is kind
of bougie mm-hmm
things are called all these complicated
names timmy's is more homely we have
Timbits was you guys called doughnut
holes they're Timbits and we have ice
caps which are like really good is
superwoman cakes at gmail.com how
embarrassing I used to make cakes and I
still kind of make cakes mm-hmm
so before I thought I would make it on
YouTube I was like I'm just gonna make
it as a baker I used to make these cakes
that were like mediocre and so I had
this gmail account his facebook page and
so I think it was still active but I
only made a cake very recently for my
day-to-day manager was a Harry Potter
cake I feel like I'm gonna die
anyways this next one is de bomb beyond
insanity
I realized I just made the water hot
yeah
it's that part of the show okay
hmm as someone who reps Scarborough
proudly what's the most Toronto thing
about Drake the fact that he says ting
20 people say ting a lot sweeter ting
hot ting crying ting there are a lot of
athletes and Hollywood stars that are
trying to put their foot print and
YouTube but I'm curious what rapper do
you think would have the best daily
vlogs if they committed to the platform
probably drink I was gonna say Will
Smith the he already is killing
Instagram I swear it's so bad
mm-hmm and I've read the opinion that
you're a better rapper than you are a
comedian and I'm curious when you look
back at your own music videos what's the
song that you're most proud of and
what's the one that you're kind of happy
was deprioritized by the algorithm he's
gonna turn to a strip show really quick
that's alright I'm really proud of
voices a rap song I have called voices
yeah
trapped on Howard's this next one is the
XRS Co oh my god
was my most painful thing remand on my
life you know Charlize Charlize Theron's
she didn't show your body she did you do
all them she was in a spot like you are
right now but she found that and rallied
to the finish line okay hold on hold on
hon hmm I'm gonna lick this one okay how
do you keep brands in check because I
have some stories to tell but you know
sometimes you'll get all this like crazy
ridiculously dumb feedback and maybe you
get a little bit incensed like why is
this brand telling me how to make a
youtube video do you ever have to deal
with that and I'm so all the time should
what I do is I write one email just
internally from my team where I'm
sassing the brand completely and it
doesn't go anywhere except for in my
team and one of my team members actually
printed and framed it and put on her
desk because it's me just being so
sarcastic but yet Brad saw me all the
time like I don't think this is the best
way to for you talk to your audience
about this brand and I'm like I've been
doing this for eight years the 14
million people watching me I really know
how to talk to my audience but I get
there's legalities and things they want
to take care of but all the time I'm
negotiating with brands but I also work
with a lot of brands I I love and who do
trust me all right Lily
I just wanna can I just have a path to
the washroom
well yeah make sure we clear the way
make sure that we clear the way do you
want some ice cream
I'm so sweet all right so this is the
last down
we call it the last dab because it's
tradition around here to put a little
extra on the last wing excuse me what do
you do you don't have to if you don't
want to Lily just put a little extra
last night you don't have to if you
don't want to what if this whole thing
is just there's nothing on yours you
know we've had people switch the paddles
before I've been challenged in that way
I always come prepared and I'm nothing
if not a man of dignity okay what I'm
gonna do what are you gonna do not bad
but I feel I cheated so I'm gonna take a
bite of the previous one that I liked
yeah yeah strong this one chase it there
it is
[Music]
gotta get my bi dumb and just one more
hurdle for you Lilly Singh we've talked
about the many sides of Lilly Singh
today entertainer entrepreneur
wrestling superfan but one thing we
haven't touched on is your parents some
of the most popular recurring characters
in the history of YouTube
Oh
the ice cream is melting yeah you're the
vicinity of my lips mm-hmm
sure legs it does it help let me tell
you my family could eat all of these and
laughs after my end they're the type of
people that when they travel abroad they
have to bring their spices with them in
the purse like I got hot sauce in my bag
Beyonce she got that from my aunt cuz
truly they can eat the spiciest thing it
will not faze them I truly believed that
my aunt could eat this and she would be
on base what happened with you I was a
doctor well you heard it here first
breaking news and look at you Lilly
Singh ten vegan chicken wings up ten
vegan chicken wings down but honestly I
was just fronting and that was no
problem
no problem at all and now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you Lillian yeah this camera
this camera this camera let the people
know what you have going on in your life
um things are really heating up in my
life I got a bunch of exciting stuff I
just started my own production company
so I'm gonna be directing and writing
and producing I have my 12 clubs
Christmas coming out which will be like
all those cool collabs you talked about
I also I'm gonna take the washroom for
30 whole minutes right now really good
job
kill some icecream I have to say that
was a hundred times worse than what I
thought it was gonna be hey it's a badge
of honor for us we'll take it hey what's
going on
spice Lords this is Sean Evans checking
in by his lonesome and you know what
that means it's time for another hot
sauce PSA and for two years we've been
working on making the perfect entry
level sauce something that's good for
everyone number one on our board and now
it is finally here the classic is our
contemporary twist on the original
vinegar-based sauces throughout American
history with chili de arbol peppers and
garlic for that perfect balance as
always people who order the hot ones
monthly subscription box got it first
but now it's available for everyone heat
nice calm heat nice calm to pick up the
classic the classic
it's for the people
[Music]